hey guys it's Jan here part of the fun
of a new Pixar movie is spotting all the
Easter eggs and references that the
animators have cleverly packed into the
film so I'm happy to say that the
studio's latest flick the good dinosaur
has plenty to keeper's Easter egg
hunters entertained with the movie out
now I've collected as many eggs and
references that I could spot in this
video I know your eagle eyes will have
noticed other fab ones too so share away
in the comments below and just a quick
reminder there are spoilers ahead so if
you're not ready for that check out my
non-spoiler review of the movie right
here after eating some rotten fruit they
found on the ground all are in spots
start laughing and hallucinating as well
as floating through the air and swapping
heads with each other they also seen
multiple eyes pop up on each other's
faces giving them a look similar to
squishy aka Scott Squibbles a character
in monsters University who just happens
to have been voiced by the good dinosaur
director Peter Sohn oh and by the way
the good dinosaur was originally meant
to be released before inside out and
after monsters University so it's no
surprise that monsters University had a
little Easter Egg for this movie in the
shape of a toy Arlo on a bedroom floor
of course although in spot-on the first
animated characters who've been drunk or
under the influence of other earth
substances for example in Disney's Dumbo
Dumbo and Timothy Q Mouse get drunk on
champagne and start hallucinating pink
and multicolored elephants and more
recently in big hero 6
baymax behaves like he's drunk when he's
low on battery when the Styracosaurus
forrest woodbush and Arlo compete to see
who gets to keep the little pooch like
human they have a naming match with each
of them suggesting names one of the
name's Arlo comes up with his spike
which also happens to be the name of the
slug-like employee or Gustus Jones at
Monsters Inc and interestingly enough -
spike was also the real name of the dog
who played Old Yeller
in the classic 1957 Disney movie which
director Peter Sohn has said was an
influence on the good dinosaur oh and I
think I also heard Arlo suggests inane
grumpy who of course is one of the Seven
Dwarves in Disney's Snow White and the
Seven Dwarves
when Arlo and spot are running away from
a bunch of pterodactyls they see what
looks like the silhouette on a doll's
Apatosaurus in the distance which is an
easter egg for the
I know cosine in Toy Story although as
they get closer they see the silhouette
is actually made up of two t-rex's the
good dinosaur also has a whole bunch of
Easter eggs to the Jurassic Park movies
when Arlo and spot ducked down behind a
rock in the middle of a plane as a herd
of Longhorns run around them it's a
definite callback to the scene in
Jurassic Park where the Gallimimus run
through the valley as a flock and dr.
grant and the kids hide behind a tree
trunk and when spot tries to hide inside
a tree trunk from the pterodactyls
trying to attack him it calls to mind
when Julianne Moore hid in a tree trunk
from a Stegosaurus in the lost world and
omars I hid inside a tree trophy from a
raptor in Jurassic world there's also a
little Lion King reference in the scene
where three Raptors approached Arlo and
spot ready to attack them which feels
very similar to when the trio of hyenas
did the same to Simba and Nala but
there's actually a fourth Raptor in the
good dinosaur and just like the scenes
in Jurassic Park where Raptors are shown
working together one of them distracting
you while the other attacks you from a
different side three Raptors take Arlo
and spots attention from the front while
a fourth one tries to pounce on them
from the back Owen the Raptor who sneaks
up on Arlo from behind is called Earl
and he's voiced by none other than
Pixar's lucky charm himself John
Ratzenberger and when the raptors jump
on Butch's back and attack him it calls
to mind the scene in Jurassic Park were
the Raptor attacks a t-rex in the
visitor center and when two Raptors goes
to attack Arlo t-rex steps in and saved
him by scooping them up in his jaws and
tossing them away just like at the end
of Jurassic Park and when the t-rex is
an Arlo roar after defeating the Raptors
it's a nice nod to the t-rex its roar at
the end of Jurassic Park and to Rasik
world oh and by the way the scenes with
Arlo and the chickens are a reminder
that birds are the closest modern
descendants of dinosaurs and they're
also a nod to paleontologist Jack Horner
who consorted on all the Jurassic Park
movies and whose research focuses on
dinosaur evolution and includes Reverse
evolving a dinosaur from a chicken and
on another dinosaur related point I kind
of felt like the asteroid belt at the
start of the movie resembled a dinosaur
skeleton with a long tail and with one
of the asteroids looking like a dinosaur
skull the phrase the storm provides
which thunderclap the
Actos leader says over and over has a
definite ring of the line the dude
abides from the Coen Brothers movie The
Big Lebowski which is well as starring
Jeff Bridges in the lead as Jeffrey the
dude Lebowski also featured actor son
Elliot who's the voice of butch the
t-rex in the good dinosaur and there's a
nice nod to the movie Jaws when the
pterodactyls return later and we see the
bottom bit of their wings sticking out
from beneath the clouds like upside down
shark fins and given that jaws is one of
the favorite films of the good dinosaurs
director Peter Sohn it's no wonder that
there's another jaws reference in the
movie to the scene where the t-rex is
sit around the campfire at night
swapping tales of how they got their
battle scars is really reminiscent of
the scene in Jaws where Richard Dreyfuss
and Robert Shaw's characters Hooper and
quince do the same Owen could this be an
ancestor of the blue-footed protagonists
of Pixar's cancelled feature film mute I
was looking for a finding Dory Easter
egg and I noticed a rock formation that
looked rather like crush the sea turtle
from Finding Nemo and although I don't
think crush will be a major part of
finding dory would it be awesome if we
had a little cario in the film by the
way in the rocks just above crush it
looks like there's the image of a sloth
which could be a shout-out to flash the
sloth from Disney's next Animated
Feature Zootopia now you're probably
wondering where Pixar's regular Easter
eggs like a113 the luxo ball and the
Pizza Planet truck are as you can
imagine and a movie set almost entirely
outdoors during the prehistoric era when
there was no modern day writing toys or
machinery those Easter eggs don't seem
to be anywhere too obvious so I think
the filmmakers have used creative
techniques to include them in the film I
found a possible a 1:13 Easter Egg and
the go for scene when our logos to blow
a gopher out of its hole for the first
time a single gopher emerges slowly and
the shape it makes is a bit like an A
then spot blows out to more Gophers one
on either side of him which could
indicate a 1 and another one and then
Arlo blows out three go for sitting on
top of each other all of which adds up
to a 113 another possibility is a scene
where Arlo puts out five sticks each one
representing one member
family the a in this case would be a for
Arlo one one would be the first two
sticks his mother and his father and
three would be the last three sticks
which are their three children so there
you have my best series at the moment
for possible a 1:13 Easter eggs let me
know what you think and if you spotted
it anywhere else in the movie I didn't
see an obvious luxo ball but look
carefully at this shot of the Sun in the
sky above the T Rexes and you'll see a
big blue ring of light around the Sun
with the Sun itself representing the
star in the look so ball and in this
close-up shot of red berries there seems
to be a five pointed star shape in the
white reflection on some of the berries
I also scoured the film for the Pizza
Planet truck the closest I found so far
is this cloud formation which as far as
cloud formations go doesn't feel like a
normal-looking cloud the shape is a
little bit blocky a bit like the Pizza
Planet truck and there's a dark blob on
top which might suggest the rocket I was
hoping to see the a113 the luxo ball and
pizza planet perhaps on a rock carving
somewhere but i didn't spot them let me
know if you noticed them anywhere else
or if you've got any theories on where
they're hidden and what about the tree
with the barriers that spot takes all OH
- it seems to have some similarities to
the Pixar tree which we first saw in a
bug's life and later in Toy Story 2 and
Earth so guys what other Easter eggs and
references did you spot in the good
dinosaur and which ones did you like
best I can't wait to read your comments
below if you're a fan of Pixar you might
want to check out my videos here 25
things you probably didn't know about
inside out and my top 10 Easter eggs and
inside out do subscribe for more of my
Easter egg videos things you know move
reviews and tons more thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers